what do you guys think of
cider cider yeah cider I'm not a big fan
I like cider I I I thought I used to be
a fan and as I've grown older I'm like I
think I'm I think I'm good actually it's
hard for me to just drink cuz like you
know when I'm when I'm drinking beer the
intention is that like okay maybe I'll
have one but like if I'm having like a
long night yeah I'll be drinking like
four beers right that's a lot of sweet
drink to consume for me well that's why
I can only drink dry Siders now like the
dry because like the sweet yeah cuz the
sweetest ciders like it it might be nice
to like maybe start off but like I can't
have a whole night with sweet ciders
also like if you really have like the
traditional cider so like I remember
when I was in when I was in Bristol uni
we'd have like some specialist cider
places and you know I was like cool
let's try some traditional cider uh
traditional cider like that that is made
like the traditional way uh some of them
just smell like feet like isn't like I I
don't know I don't know what the
traditional way to make is but I'm
pretty sure they just left some apples
in a [__] barrel for months and just
let them it down with
like probably why it smells like feet
yeah just bare feet just crushing these
app that wasn't even the worst part some
some of them are just like lukewarm you
know some of them you know in the UK I
think you'd often get served pretty warm
beers and ciders yeah it's generally a
bit War I don't understand warm beers
well not war okay not warm sorry but
like it's not I wouldn't Des that is not
a hot T Joey I just I know it's not a
hot I just don't get it I've had it
before and I'm just like do you I think
the I'm going to poor mud's going to
fact check this I'm pretty sure the idea
is is that warm beer is much easier to
drink more of than a colder beer hold on
I'm just going to look at the window
real quick just to make
sure maybe I'm just if I was a bar owner
I would want people to drink more beer I
just I don't think people need
convincing in the UK to drink more true
true sure sure flavor flavor okay flavor
I'm pretty sure though like if the alol
is war doesn't it go to your head
quicker like it it gets you're just
making [__] up now
SAR no no no I no I'm pretty sure if the
beer or alcohol is is warmer or room
temp it it gets in your bloodstream
quicker than it does if it's cold so
what you're saying is
like wine will get around your body
quicker than like a c glass white wine
yeah of course anecdotally this is
complete [__] Nole
it
anecdotally but when you open when you
put the window just say no yeah an like
anecdotally like I you know they say
that you get more drunk when you drink
on a plane because of the high altitude
and stuff I think that's true I'll test
it tonight I'll I'll let you know I'll
let you know actually one time I CU I
normally if I have I'm going on the
plane right after this so I guess I'll
well I'll probably just have a beer
before I fall asleep to help because
it's the worst feeling is drinking a
bunch of beer and then you don't go to
bed for like 4 hours and then you go to
bed you're
like oh
God cuz your body's like trying to
digest all of it I was on this flight
one time uh and I don't know why one of
the I I asked for an alcohol free beer
uh cuz I had a meal and I was like yeah
I want I want the taste of beer without
alcohol but that's not the taste of beer
it's it no no no I I I've been trying to
swap out beer for non-alcoholic lately
yeah um and I know it's yeah well listen
I'm calories it's mainly calories don't
drink beer well no sometimes you're in
the the mood where you people everyone's
having a beer and you want to join in
but you don't want to have the alcohol
so I'll just get the non-alcoholic
version cuz it scratches the same like
beer taste that's cing bro no genuinely
genuinely it's it's it doesn't taste the
same in my op in my opinion it doesn't
taste the same it doesn't taste the same
but it it it's close enough where like I
feel like if I'm around everyone and
everyone's Beering I'm like all right
well I feel like I'm part of it just and
zero cops and zero calories no I think
it tastes metallic just just drink a
Seltzer at that point man I just don't
want the
calories yeah that's that's why I said
yeah drink a Sala we still have 100
calories I want zero I want zero I don't
I don't want the alcohol as well don't
want the alcohol mainly as well cuz I'm
like man I got to do [__] tomor but for
to preface this is not us giving [__] to
our mate for not wanting to drink
alcohol really right now speak for
yourself I'm definitely shaming this not
what this is not what is happening but
I'm trying to make you the argument list
listen I I we booze and Smo a lot you
know uh we have beers occasionally and I
just kind of figured out I was like man
if I'm going to drink uh which ends up
happening like once a week at least in
Japan like if I could just change one of
those days to being no alcohol I'm like
okay well maybe my body will thank me a
little bit more for it oh no I I
completely agree totally and it's like I
said like it's not the exact same taste
but it's close enough for me where I'm
like okay it just about gets that itch
of beer although man does it give me
like the grossest smelling mouth and and
burps for some reason non-alcoholic beer
at least the Japanese ones smell
horrific yeah they smell like coins it's
awful I don't know why it's a metallic I
burp and I like nearly vomit yeah it's
gross like but it's only 100 calories no
it's
zero zero calories and zero carobs wait
non-alcoholic beer in Japan the the uh
the the Sor olree and the green label
aahi no green label is alcoholic the the
non-alcoholic Asahi and santor have zero
well I two grams of Cobbs yeah uh or one
I don't know what wasse and zero
calories and zero alcohol and zero
sugars I me so it's like a it's like a
Coke Zero for
alcoholics just [__] drink uh water
at the end of the day well yeah I mean
like like I've heard of that before no
no no no but like it's like again like
you want to you want to be a part of it
and sometimes you know it's it feels
kind of lame to order a uh a [__]
water when everyone else's got beer but
like at least order sparking water oh
okay all right pantic I don't know man I
don't [__] judge if someone's like
that at a hangout it's like all right
you know what
like I don't judge I'm like I don't I'm
not judging your stance on not want
drink alcohol I am judging the [__]
Taste of alcoholic beer which I I've had
enough times at like the when I've tried
to make the same decisions and I don't
know it's it's kind of like being cucked
by beer cuz like you're having you you
you think you're having beer but like
it's it's just not the same
fullness taste I'm drinking beer but
it's notal controversal I've been
drinking I think non-alcoholic aahi
tastes better than aah do you just not
like beer what the [__] are you do do
not like I love beer okay how dare you g
how dare how dare you say I don't like
beer it's the one thing in life I love G
dude you just I don't know cuz for me I
either want a good tasting whatever like
a good tasting beer or I don't want it
at all like I remember like Connor every
time we'd hang hang out uh early on you
would drink the green labels which is
like the low calorie beer awful beer
right and it tastes awful it tastes
[__] that was mainly cuz I wanted to
get at the time it's like a trying to
get to the the drunk vibe
and I wanted to do it without murdering
my body but it would come at the C of
just having the worst tasting beer it's
actually legally not recognized as beer
in Japan because of the way it's made it
can't be called beer really yeah and and
it's it's so [__] it's called H hopu A
ha it's not like it can't I don't think
it's it can legally be called and
referred to as beer no it's referred to
as H which what what does that mean in
hosu just means like uh bubbly alcohol
yeah right like it's it's I guess it's
kind of like it's the closest you'll get
to like the calories of non-alc
non-alcoholic beer but keeps the alcohol
it's like Hasbro is my first beer but I
actually think that the alcohol in that
because the beer tastes so bad the
alcohol makes it taste worse but least
because the nonalcoholic isn't alcoholic
it's just like it's okay yeah I I don't
know like for for me how can I say this
does beer taste good I love the taste of
beer I don't know okay I do not know
okay genuinely I do not know if I like
the taste of beer cuz it tastes good or
if because I've like beer peed myself
into thinking it tastes good you know
cuz Okay okay every kid remembers their
first sip of beer right and you remember
that first sip of beer and you're like
yeah but as a kid you don't eat [__]
chicken nuggets if I gave them to you KH
do you remember the exact place beer uh
I do remember there was a turning point
uh around like the age of like 20 where
I started to think huh this is pretty
refreshing for me it wasn't until I
moved to Japan and that had Japanese
beer that I realized wow Australian
beers taste like dirt I was like wow
this is actually good beer like loggers
and psers like very and they also like I
mean aahi and is like it's it's like
water yeah but cuz like my first like
reaction or I guess like my f my initial
reaction to beer or what I thought was
like this is what all beer tastes like
is [__] VB which is like the
worst you have to start with the worst
so you can appreciate like you know you
have to have
but in my brain I was like oh if this is
what all beer tastes like then I don't
think I ever want to drink beer ever
again and then when I you know came to
Japan and I started drinking all the
Japanese brands I was just like oh this
is actually like kind of nice yeah I
think I remember telling my parents like
I'm never going to drink alcohol it
tastes so bad and then they laughed at
me and then years later they keep
bringing it up yeah my dad laughed at me
and he was just like you're Australian
son you're going to
drink it's like if you are my son you
are going to drink um I mean yeah I just
love the taste of beer I wish that there
was more non-alcoholic beers that tasted
good so I wouldn't feel bad about
drinking them cuz sometimes I'm like man
I wish I could I could have a beer in
this occasion but I'm like man I just
don't want to have alcohol it's like
[__] but I love the taste of beer itself
uh but only really beer I never get like
I never really like want to drink I
never ever want to [__] drink Spirits
they're [__] disgusting I don't think
I like beer enough to the point where I
just want the taste of beer but I want
the taste of beer but I don't want
alcohol I don't I don't love beer as
much [__] I love I love the bitterness I
love the the carbonation I love the kind
of hoppiness of it it's just a and it
goes well with food so well any food you
have tastes so good with beer or fried
food fried food but any like anything
really I I think anything tastes good
beer food and you you tell me any food I
I'll say it tastes good with beer Sushi
I think it tastes great with beer no no
no
no it's too light man it's too light T I
think it tastes good